un dispositif exceptionnel à la hauteur
des événements qui ont secoué
Saint-Aignan l'année dernière près de
250 gendarmes ont été déployés pour
quadrier la petite commune de tzé c'est
à la sortie de ce virage que Luigi
dukenet avait trouvé la mort le gendarme
auteur des tirs et le conducteur de la
voiture oncle de la victime sont
présents pour participer à la
reconstitution des faits le procureur de
la République de Blois Dominique puchma
a fait boucler la ville à partir de 14h
le mot d'ordre est clair journalistes et
habitants doivent être maintenus à
l'écart de la zone de l'incident
personne ne doit venir troubler le
déroulement de la reconstitution vous
vous essayez systématiquement de
m'amener sur le fond du dossier et je
vous ai indiqué que je ne parlerai pas
du fond du dossier pour raison parce que
nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
instruction judiciaire et que le code de
procédure pénale prévoit que
l'instruction judiciaire est
secrète je ne dérogerai pas à ce
principe le 16 juillet 10 vers 22h la
Renault 19 Beig déboule dans le village
poursuivie par deux véhicules de la
gendarmerie Luigi ducenet a déjà
renversé un gendarme et un barrage a été
dressé pour arrêter le véhicule en face
de l'église deux balles atteignent la
voiture le passagier Luigi est
mortellement blessé quelques kilomètres
plus loin son corps est retrouvé sur le
bas côté à l'heure qu'il est la
reconstitution est toujours en cours
elle devrait se poursuivre jusque tard
dans la nuit